.
AEL SM
ONLYO SOEW.MED BY SMAGH KNOWN
MONDN A WHEN I WILK
PA THE PUBLIC LEASE OF WARRANV
E ERD
TRUTH, YRE MKE
L STRE WAS THE FIRST TO TA RETR,
SECRET, AND
OVERNMENT LI OF ITEMS REMOVED FA
0 BOXES OF ITEMS AS WELL
ONE HANDWRITTEOTOS
STONE.SONCLUDEINFORMATION ABOUTC
CO THR-PE
LIT NED INENT ALINCLUDES THE WR
ED T
DOCUS,EVT P SECRET SENSITIVE
IT ALSO SAYSCOLLEC TOP SECRES OE
DOTHRETSF NFIDENOCUMEN
MO
DOCUMENTS.
TO THE
BASTMAON
ND
DEMOCRATIC CO-RKTHE
THE DEMOCRAT
AHHEMES"
RSDAY THERE WA
HEN TRUMP DIDN'T COMPLHEARCH WA
HOUSE E.HE FEDS FILE A EE TO
MPE
ANDEF TRUM
REALLY WAS AE  PRODUT D INVENTYE
MEANINGLESS.
SHOW U
PUBLICST" SAID THERE WERNTS RELI
S SIGNED O.
EXED OMO NOTN
D AGAIT UMP.
D NOW EVIDENCE BDA  GOING BACK.
ESPECIALLY WHEN CLOSE TOSDAY THE
PRESIDENT HIMSELF REED
STEMT CALLING TH
UN-AMERICAN,D ALREADY BY THEN K
TH PDE
ERREPUBLTRIO RONAL
H.-W BUSH ANOR EVER TRUMPER.
E ATLANTIC
TON JUSTICAEL MILITANT RP'S HO
HE SPEAKERCHBI
R OF
THESE PEOPS
O WANT TYOU.
FONE THEY'RE NOT DEIN IS THE WOO
TH OTHURSDY WHO WAHEWAY
G UP ARMED A IOHIOHENTFOD O POSE
OLE RACHEDDD  G
Y PELOSI
THE AN -PRESIDENT.
EN COLBERT POSITEL
TW  LINCO
BELATED HAPP
EM MAT THE, THEY WERE R
WOND COU GO DOWN
AL CAPONE?
ST THERE WAS THIS OM
AN, TOO. D MEANS THAT IFIF THESE
ER AGREES, THERE'S T
THINGS WIL
AS BROOKS WRITESTHNE" UNDER THEE
I JUSTLD
AMERICA ABSOLUTELY NEEDS T
PUNISH THOSE WHOMI O
DS
S NOOTHETERM
VEHEERLIKELY?
NF L L
HERES S AL
BREATH.
ST
D HOPEFULLY WEIN THE KEPWHY DIH?
AND WES S ASIN NATURE?
RTARCH E
WAWAED?OSE ARE MYSTIONS.
TO RELATED.GO TSMERCONISH.COM.
ANESTIONAR O
UMING TH NOMINEE?
I'LLS AT HOUR.GUG HIS ER HADHE
ONSIBILITYUSE
VARIOUVEF CLASSI
INCLUDING THE TOET SCISENSITIVEM
RECOVEREO.INING ME NOW IS
LIEUTEK HURT D S
OF THE FIRST AOR
ANT OFY EUROPE AND .GEH FOR  SC
>> WELL, AS MICHAEL,ANDS FORVECO
SCI ISD INFORMATION RSL,T CLEAR
OM FROM SENSITIVE LLIGENCE
IG OSOE
R NATIONS DO
METR ANALYTICAL
H WITFORMALSS ESTABLISHED BY T
E ALL SORT
NTOF
ANHETSTED SOARLIE TSES
THAT PEOWH A
NEO WHT HAVEHET CLASSIFICATIONTH
'T SEE I
Y  S.A.P. OR ANY
REFERENCE TO NUCLEAR JUST IN S N
GO ATTEN IEYOOW, GENERAL, NOT L
O THE TYPE O
TO GET ELECTED PRESIDENTIN
OF U, IT'S UMED THAT YOU'NTAT LO
T
KNOW THIS,IC
WHU  SECURITO MATTERHA CONFIDEN
ONAL S, THEING DETAILOF THE ON
LIVED, NAMES OF YO TEACHERS,
NAMES OF YOUD IGHBORS AND KINDSH
HAVE DONE HE PAS
YOU'RE NOT -TIMET
REALLY PROUDAT AGENTAL ON OR CI
ONLY TO
ERVIEWS T E OF PEOPL I
THGSE ANYWHERE SO PEOPLE THA N O
TO
LYUNDER ADDITIONAL
IRY THINGS A OW
T THAT.
ED.
AN BEEN THROUGIT
T ITCI
R PRESIDENT -- T SCI PROGRAMIS B
YOULLIGENCE OFF TO OTHERS THAT K
ORMEESSTT EN
HE WOULD TAKMEACK TO T RESIDENC
G RLD,E TAKE ME OUR WORK.
>> WL,HAEL, I'M LAWYER.T?
SO A C I MIGHTE ONOLOMON OX . UM
EVANT.
IN GOCLASSIFIED INFORMATION
ANYON
SUPPORTS THEM AS THEY  I'MT OTH
GOVENTT LIVES AT RISK.ITS OUR N
CUN DANGER.
AND TO ME,US A
EHE.
U  MY OWN
THOUGHTS
MYSTNIGHT EN SAW TT FI